si vous riez vous perdez un point je
vous rappelle que l'équipe perdante
entre les chroniqueurs de TPMP et la
bande à Fifi devra manger la chips la
plus piquante du monde je vous jure que
ce dernier mec qui va manger
il non il est payant les Chéries Julien
Mathieu attention à pas dire regardez
premier
c'est parti
bonjour je m'appelle Dylan prenez garde
à la fermeture automatique des portes
notre train à destination de
Bourg-d'Oisans va partir attention au
départ
[Musique]
[Rires]
mesdames messieurs notre bateau à
destination de Marseille Saint-Charles
va partir prenez garde attention notre
bateau va couler
[Musique]
viens là un petit coup mesdames
messieurs notre train à destination de
C8 où il vole pas rigoler c'est pas
drôle mais va partir quand même
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement il est incroyable je te jure
et il faut il est pas incroyable j'ai
pensé à la mort de ma grand-mère tout le
monde
on te kiffe bravo je te jure je l'adore
tu me tues de rien
mais moi tu sais que je peux pas c'est
incroyable
est-ce que tu peux me faire
est-ce que tu peux nous faire
juste pour les téléspectateurs juste un
train qui croise un bateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Paris j'étais en train de dormir le
producteur adjoint il m'appelle j'étais
en train de dormir et tout il y a un
producteur adjoint oui ben regarde
et du coup j'ai ma collègue Lise et
Jordan ils sont venus me chercher ils
m'ont ramené à la gare de Grenoble merci
[Applaudissements]
LAN un peu là dedans
merci et Dylan je le kiffe c'est un
amour de mec et je te jure c'est avoue
que c'était en bas le début j'ai cru que
j'avais la tête et je veux tellement
leur montrer
c'est très dur attention deuxième
j'appelle j'appelle Guillaume Genton et
Elodie
[Applaudissements]
pour pour que ce soit mon équipe qui va
la chips
regardez
si on sourit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est très très bon on peut dire David
Bastien qui était avec nous
[Applaudissements]
on embrasse pas c'est Guillaume
la chanson
le doigt dans le cul n'existe pas c'est
une chanson
[Applaudissements]
en troisième cabine j'appelle Valérie
Benaim et Fifi
allez-y il y a un jeune homme qui va
venir voilà
[Musique]
je me présente je m'appelle Younes
beatboxer professionnelle et à mes temps
perdu je suis un mangeur d'oignon
tu as 200 ans c'est insupportable
tu as des problèmes auditifs tu
comprends pas ce qui se passe dans
l'émission t'as vraiment pas vraiment
mais je te le dis moi où tu te fais à
parier on arrête de se covoit
[Musique]
tu as peur de me regarder
[Rires]
maintenant je vais vous montrer mon
talent beatboxer
[Musique]
Younes
[Applaudissements]
on peut applaudir Younès qui est très
fort beatbox
[Applaudissements]
vous savez celui qui est amoureux de
Nadia ou alors des fois j'arrive même à
faire des petits imitations de dauphins
je suis HS alors on peut faire on peut
faire un duo
qui passe vas-y
[Rires]
merci
d'avoir été la version la première fois
tu restes
j'adore
là les gars vous allez certainement rire
de tristesse
de tristesse malheureusement si parce
que c'est la prochaine personne qui
arrive c'est triste ce qu'elle va faire
je vais rappeler Julien et Raymond
[Applaudissements]
avec toi
[Rires]
c'est déjà tombé tout à l'heure
qui va bouffer l'oignon
[Rires]
ah oui chacun en plus moi je peux pas je
vomisse
[Rires]
le document une seule de la semaine
Raymond Abou un chauffeur livreur nicker
il a fait 250 millions de km de Ferrari
je te prends un seul filo hop un seul
routier une star internationale
25 millions d'entrées à travers le monde
c'est le document italien je te pose le
film dans la lumière hop c'est pour moi
c'est cadeau c'est 50 Minutes Inside
salut fils salut camarade à la semaine
prochaine
alors là typiquement chez vous si vous
nous regardez à 19h20 voilà ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire
tu reviens demain pour la chronique tu
reviens demain pour la chronique je
reviens demain
à ne pas rire
[Rires]
merci c'est fait chier à se maquiller
pour faire ça non mais c'est horrible
la dernière la dernière targue viens moi
je ne pouvais rester bref si toi tu peux
valider
parce que là on vous a sponteux
attention je crois savoir ce que c'est
et je sais pas ouais attention tu joues
pour qui ils sont pour vous bande de
cons je te fais parti de votre bande
il faut pas que c'est la bande à Fifi
contre
la bande-annonce
de
changer
allez c'est parti il a dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au ralent
I
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au bout de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est-ce que ça va ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et également
merci Hafida